hello there reject nation we got
ourselves the second most likely final
trailer for light year if you can go to
infinity beyond but leave a like that
would be very much appreciated apologies
for being late to this and looking a bit
out of it i was up late at night
listening to johnny depp testify for
like six hours gotta keep up to date for
all you kids out there who are also
light year fans and wanting to keep up
with the celebrity trial of the century
anywho let's get to this
[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who are you talking uh no one you were
narrating again i was not just doing the
mission log you do know no one ever
listens to that i know that narrating
helps me focus
the trick
ready as i'll ever be commander
hawthorne this is exciting a new
adventure i'm gonna grant you four
minutes to be off planet but then you'll
come right back to us
to infinity and beyond
anywhere clear e.t touch
piece has stopped buzz that was utterly
terrifying and i regret having joined
you
buzz lightyear to star command come in
star command
why don't they answer
hi
it's just all back line from the first
one
alicia oh no that's my grandmother but
sucks how long were we gone
62 years seven months and five days
what time did [ __ ] i hope you're ready
for action because all we needed was a
pilot for what to destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team darby
can take any three things and make them
explode
wow they shave a little time off my
sentence okay and what about you well i
thought this was going to be like a fun
boot camp workout thing taker
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need the
anyone seen the
harpoons right here
[Applause]
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is thirty eight point
two percent that seems a bit low
failure imminent
grandma always said she believed in you
too
that was a big swelling too i think i
need a bed at least record your last
words do not vomit inside the vehicle
you're not vomiting
this recording speak or select one
inside the vehicle
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that ugh sorry it's the thing
your grandma and i used to do yeah
only in theaters did you guys read that
only in theaters the first pixar movie
only be in theaters but should we watch
this in theaters and then do a review
for you guys right out of the theater or
should we wait for it to come out on
disney plus and then do a reaction for
you guys here on the channel you guys
let us know and then we'll still make
our own choice and yeah will you let us
know either way we want to know what
you're doing we'll take it heavily into
consideration regardless that was a fun
trailer that was revealing 62 years they
said 62 years
my god that's so sad that time dilation
crap in space babies and [ __ ] really
just always bumps yeah that's a such a
sad fact my gosh yeah because to her
grandma like you know buzz just left and
never came back probably you know took a
lot of her uh life you know
sentimentality with very
interstellar-ish what was interesting is
that the other trailers they had like
the cosmic space adventure vibe you get
a lot more of that like ethereal plane
quality to it yet this one really amped
up the action adventure side of the
space traveling this one had like a
really good pulse to it whereas the
other ones were more wondrous this was
like exciting yeah
a little bit more pulse-pounding i'm
forgetting this story we're watching is
supposedly
this story that is from the movie that
is in the toy story world like the buzz
lightyear action figure is based on that
i i keep forgetting
how to properly surmise what it is the
conceit is it's the story of the real
life astronaut who then inspired the toy
you see you said that too you said real
life astronaut this is just a movie
character right yeah it's not an actual
real life astronaut i think so i read
the quote again and i'm still a little
unclear guys tell john if he's right or
wrong i'm because he says like there's a
real life astronaut within this world
and i'm under the impression that it's
just a a movie here just a movie that
inspired the toy yes well either way
that's the case you don't know that
question everyone wants this movie a
biopic you know what i just realized
about that reference that they said
when he's like well it's like your star
command why won't they answer
what's really cool about that it's more
than just a like a reference it actually
makes you go back to the first toy story
movie makes you kind of wonder is buzz
just acting out the movie like as part
of the toy is he acting out the story in
that moment you know when he is like
looking around woody's bedroom and then
does and does say like why won't they
answer i love how that can like
completely tie back into it all would
make sense why all the buzz lightyears
are sort of responding that way and why
they have a harder time realizing that
they are a toy
yeah yeah now i'm wondering are we going
to see the confrontation of you know him
and zerg's relationship or is that
something that they simply added as a
canon for the toys but not the actual
movie itself because you know toy story
2 you get that crucial connection of oh
my god zerg is buzz's daddy and is that
gonna be the case here are we gonna see
that again or are we gonna see how they
fell out or are we just gonna ignore
that detail all together uh i'm gonna
throw my arms up and rage if that ends
up being the case though john i know
that if they do not acknowledge that
then i'm going to be like why did i sit
through this movie then yeah what's the
canon even for what freaking lazy ass
pixar writers man please get taking note
of the star wars book so apparently
hawthorne is a is a don't say gay
character oh good yeah
what happened was there was like a
same-sex kiss that happened and they cut
it out but after that whole thing was
like disney defending the whole thing
about don't say gay and now they have
restored that in this movie restore the
gay a verse and uh yeah this will be a i
think is this gonna be like disney
animated's first gay character it very
well could be is it the first for pixar
you know i'm not i'm not certain i think
it's really i think it's a fascinating
update because you know they just always
cut those scenes out for china anyway so
they'll add it back in for the rest of
the world cut it back out for china hey
man if that's the case i'm happy for
them go hawthorne live your best life i
love that trope where the grandchild
looks exactly
like like rapper yeah
so much so damn it shakes you for that
person yeah yeah
it seems like that it's going to be a
really cool fun movie that plays on sort
of like uh like that 1960s discovering
space that'll be the the quality of it
even though it will take place in the
future when he is probably maroon on
this planet uh you know after the time
dilation experience probably be a little
bit more wall-e feeling and then it goes
back to the fun with this group of
ragtag misfits who are here saving buzz
lightyear so this looks like a really
fun time absolutely and it looks like
it's going to draw from every sci-fi
movie ever made it looks like it's
pulling from oblivion
john carter
definitely john carpenter's ghosts of
mars
pitch black black uh-huh yeah all the
chronicles have written all the
chronicles already films red planets
mission to mars and uh space cowboys a
little bit in here uh event horizon yes
this is pulling from mainly
mainly really very adult some types of
uh
baseball so we'll see how this turns out
for children across the globe all right
guys well what did you think about this
light year trailer leave your thoughts
down below subscribe to the real rejects
let's do a
chase gardener when thinking about what
this trailer just revealed about buzz
lightyear's adventure your name is just
the most perfectly suitable to describe
this chase gardener you got the other
space people chasing after buzz
lightyear buzz is chasing after an
adventure and then when you think about
it you know buzz maroon there for a
while kind of like matt damon in that
one mars movie he was in and what does
he do he becomes a gardener of sorts now
by definition of this light year movie
you are
the buzz lightyear of our patreon page
you are a sexy reject now with that in
mind we got to go to infinity and beyond
meaning you got to be with us for
infinity and you got to pledge way way
more than ever it's time to go broke by
giving all your life savings to the real
rejects patreon page my god you're just
such a good guy dude generosity thank
you everyone else can unpledge now
because chase is taking care of everyone
this round's on chase
[Music]
you